questa è una storia relativamente molto
breve ma che non possono raccontare sul
canale quindi chiedo scusa se questo
video dura veramente poco adesso vi
spiego esattamente di che cosa stiamo
parlando storiella time a dicembre non
so se lo sapete tutti però insomma
motivo lo sanno ho fatto un film ho
fatto ho partecipato in un film che il
film nel milanese imbruttito che si
chiama mollo tutto da pronunci l'invito
ho partecipato al film c'erano anche
altri guest come claudio bisio e le tra
lamborghini e jake la furia è stata una
bellissima esperienza soprattutto la
prima del film quando si gira un film
poi c'è la prima sostanziale della prima
proiezione del film che viene fatta di
consueto con il red carpet che cos'è
carpet questo tappeto rosso avrete
sicuramente visto le prime dei film agli
oscar c'è questo tappeto rosso gigante
dove il cast del film scambia qualche
parola con i giornalisti si fa le foto
di rito davanti a questo muro con il
poster del film in questione è anche per
i film del milanese imbruttito nel quale
ho partecipato c'è stata la prima del
film questo è il luogo dove si svolge la
nosta breve ma intensissima vicenda non
che figura ci arriviamo niente c'è
questo red carpet gigante io mi vesto
con la mia col mio smoking dove lo metto
tre volte all'anno e questo era un
evento importantissimo non potevo
mettere lo smoking quindi io il mio
personale manager l'attuale ermanno che
avete già conosciuto nel video di ogni
gol sono su ci avviamo all'anteprima del
film siccome a dicembre faceva un freddo
porco ho preso prima di uscire da casa
ho preso un giubbotto dall'armadio in
modo tale da arrivare poi al red carpet
per potermelo poi toglierlo per togliere
facilmente di manierismo king e fare le
foto prendiamo il taxi e andiamo al
cinema arriviamo al cinema scendiamo dal
taxi ci avviciniamo appunto al red
carpet nel quale io sarei dovuto entrare
io ho la malaugurata idea di mettere le
mani in tasca dentro il giubbotto e
succede una cosa sento quando metto la
mano nel giubbotto la forma di un
qualcosa di plastica o riconosciuto che
cosa fosse quell'oggetto fatidico nella
tasca del giubbotto che non prendevo da
un sacco di tempo e tra me e me ho detto
perché un preservativo in tasca perché
era rimasto un preservativo nella tasca
di quel giubbotto double non so
ovviamente incartato ci mancherebbe mi
faccio un pensiero molto lungimirante e
dico io che conosco alla perfezione la
mia vita so di per certo che se tengono
questo preservativo in tasca non so come
ma in un modo o nell'altro durante la
serata io una figura di ma sicuramente
mela sparo quindi penso di fare una cosa
molto furba prendo io lo prendo e lo
infilo nella tasca di ermanno subito
dopo averlo fatto
bisbiglio all'orecchio di armano gli
dico armi
ascolta ho infilato la mano nella mia
tasca in questo giubbotto ho sentito che
c'era un preservativo è però messo in
tasca 15 è un mio preservativo chiuso in
tasca cioè in tasca poi se vuoi
ridarmelo sono usalo per i casi di
dolore però l'ho tolto perché
sicuramente visto che sono in mezzo
miliardo di telecamere non vorrei mai
che succedesse qualcosa piace quindi che
fai sappi che ci hai un condom lui mi
guarda si mette a ridere tantissimo dice
va bene
arriviamo al red carpet
io mi tolgo il mio giubbotto e faccio le
foto di rito davanti a
al poster no era questo era il poster è
questa la carpet benissimo siccome è
proprio bello il momento in cui
fotografi scattano le foto in genere c'è
sempre qualcuno che riprende la scena
dall'esterno dove ci sono tutti quanti
che dicono e guardami girati è un bel
sorriso una bella posa ok questo
qualcuno è appunto armando che ben
avrebbe passato il video per poterlo
ricaricare appunto sui miei social il
problema è che il telefono di armano
stava nella tasca la stessa tasca dove
stava il preservativo e siccome quello
era un momento abbastanza concitato
ermanno si dimentica della presenza di
questo oggetto mistico nella sua tasca
quindi sfila il telefono per farmi il
video io ero già lì che mi sto facendo
le foto a una decina di metri di
distanza
sfila il telefono dalla tasca e inizia a
riprendermi mi stava riprendendo mentre
facevo le foto di quanto segue
c'è il video ed è questo
[Musica]